oscar pill dawson avait donné le nom
d'une place à l'un de ses plus grands
succès les placer où se situe le
quartier des modes montréal où je suis
né c'est maintenant l'un vers ce qui se
produit le maharajah du piano comme le
surnommaient duke ellington aura une
place en son honneur
serait notre ville cet espace sera niché
dans le réaménagement prévu de l'avenue
mcgill college en 2023 et là entre
sainte-catherine et maisonneuve
une fontaine de la verdure une place
entièrement piétonne ce lieu a été
préféré à la place des festivals c'est
au coeur de la cité
c'est pas seulement un endroit dédié à
la culture est un endroit dédié à toute
la vie de l'urbanité de montréal et pour
la veuve d'oscar pill aussonne c'est
l'endroit parfait
oscar peterson était le mentor du
pianiste oliver jones on les voit ici à
montréal en 2004 interprétant just
friends lui aussi a fait le déplacement
pour l' annonce
et
pour la ville cet hommage dépasse le
seul musicien il faut pas oublier non
plus que messieurs pires scènes de par
la couleur de sa peau a vécu beaucoup
discrimination et de racisme de cette
future place d'environ 500 mètres carrés
donc un peu d'envergure selon la ligue
des noirs si loin d'être suffisant
compte tenu de l'importance de la
grandeur de passe car peter seuls dans
l'univers musical du jazz c'est en tout
cas davantage que le petit parc qui
porte actuellement son nom dans la
petite bourgogne
ce quartier lawson est mort il y a déjà
quatorze ans il continue de donner
d'achat beaucoup ici mathieu poste radio
canada montréal